my microphone is on all of your
microphones are on hello everyone and
welcome to I don't know this like
impromptu you thing that I really wanted
to put together to show the dramatic
diversity of opinions in the loss of his
party
you will have just heard my stream just
came through that's fine
I did want to on the very top of the
show today no that's the wrong one why
are we going image yeah to talk about
some of the really serious allegations
that I've been coming on the games
injures industry today I considered
postponing this but mostly just wanted
to say I can say firsthand that a lot of
this stuff is very real and it is
infuriating to continue watch people to
assume that women are lying and also if
you're an ally please be a better
[ __ ] ally because a lot of people let
people in positions of power who are
doing things that we absolutely should
not tolerate get away with it because
it's easier so believe people when they
come forward I'm not telling you to
believe everything you read but don't
assume everyone is lying that [ __ ]
sucks and is extremely unfair and do
better if you're an ally support people
that is that is my main takeaway here
all right so time to introduce everyone
we have Phil it's his birthday he is in
the hands of the 5 out of 10 side we
have Jess it is not her birthday she is
also 5 out of 10 side we have Jeff I
hope we don't confuse Justin Jeff too
much Jeff is in the 10 out of 10 camp
and then right down the bottom that we
have Khalif who is also in the 10 out of
10 camp I like how it doesn't say your
name it just says spawn on me podcast
but also I changed my name
huge shout out to the podcast it is it
is really really good I've been loving
what you guys been putting out so the
knows how to promote himself right it
has business title straight from the
German so I wanted to start this off
with a question that has been one of the
most confusing things that I've seen
just a lot of people talking about in
regards to this game because I wanted to
get a feel of how you people with very
different opinions for the record I
forgot to say I feel like I'm in a 7 out
of 10 so I'm very much between everyone
here the one thing that I have found the
hardest to relate to
I would love to hear if any of you
disagree ultimately is the idea that
this game disrespects Joel as a
character from my perspective he is he's
beloved and everyone kind of does
everything they do very much because of
him he's shown in a really positive
light in a lot of ways I just whoever
wants to take the floor how do we feel
about Joel's representation spoiler
territory brother yeah yeah already kind
of touch on that
this is Joel's game I barely think this
is Ellie's game and yeah this whole game
is about dads and dealing Joel sins I'm
dealing with grief over Joel her whole
motivation is about Joel it's extremely
sympathetic towards him and assumes that
you are as the player as well yeah so I
don't figure with that at all I think
Joel's the villain of this game I take
my take just subjectively as I was
playing it is that the the decision that
is that I object to most vehemently is
the decision that Joel makes do not save
humanity I feel like that's the villain
that's the what a villain does and I
understand we're supposed to feel a
little sympathetic to that and and but I
as a father myself I know it would be a
difficult thing to sacrifice my daughter
I feel like that's why the end of the
first game is I think one of the best
video game endings ever and I remember
when they announced a pot to that I was
like I just don't know that I want this
because I felt like it was such a
perfect ending to a video game in that
it is a complicated thing I felt like at
the time everyone was in agreement on
that people really disagree with it now
where I was like isn't it so good
because you understand why he does what
he does but at the same time you know
you have to literally take into question
the whole of humanity there was no
guarantee that the surgery was going to
they could have killed her and it might
not have worked we have that that's that
is a factor in this this whole thing but
I feel like no matter what he was never
supposed to come out of that the 100%
the hero he was always doing something
that was in theory wrong and you do see
in the game when Ellie finds out she
seems really [ __ ] mad at him for
saving what you mean II don't know never
you need to murder everyone right he
didn't need to murder every he could
have gotten her out of there without
murdering everyone video game a big
phone I have to pick this game it's
minor in my grand scheme of things but
the fact that this game assumes that I
killed the doctor I did not kill the
[ __ ] doctor and and that pisses me
off because it gave me some hint of a
choice I remember people with like
designers I don't know if it was Neil
druckmann specifically but designers
talking about from Naughty Dog talking
about how they gave you this choice
right and most people took it I did it
because I don't feel at all sympathy I
was like I understood the relationship
of the difficulty of the choice but I
think ultimately I disagree with and in
this game and this perspective is that
vigil is a good father
he might not be a good guy he's a good
father he protects his daughter I don't
think he does because I think the
problem is that this game completely
disregards that Ellie wanted asked to be
if it comes down to that she heavily
implied do it and he ignored that and
then all of a sudden she like I think
she should be madder at him he has put
the burden of literally murdering the
entire world on her shoulders why is he
so why is this whole game her avenging
this man that's what my fundamentally I
think why it's sympathetic or thinks I'm
sympathetic towards Joel or have some
love for him that is precious enough for
me to think that putting the new love of
my life's like life in danger
well what what you're describing I think
speaks to this the issue you're
describing speaks to just how broken the
structure of the game is yes like you
wouldn't understand why she decides to
rampage if they put you know there's a
scene probably a third of the way into
the game where you find
now that Ellie and Joel had their
falling-out Manali found out about the
whole you know the the big murders that
Joel did then when Joel just
single-handedly wiped out you know a
hundred people in the world he fire fly
a base like the fact that they just hit
that for so long it's just like this is
a primary like the fact that they were
on on the outs and the fact that Ellie
will have regrets about that you know
about about being estranged from the
person that she was closest with to that
point like that's why she goes on a
rampage to me but the fact that they
hold that back for so long until much
later than the information is really
like emotionally useful I feel like the
rampage makes sense to me because of the
way that he was killed like I'd want to
[ __ ] kill Abby I did I was like I
want all of you to die and so for that
chunk of the game I was very motivated
I lose my motivation in the second half
of the game where I did really like
learning about what the WLF are doing I
really found that interesting I like
seeing that campus I like seeing how
well oiled it is they are like a city to
Jackson's country homey vibe the
difference between the two of them is so
dramatic and I really liked getting that
insight look all the stuff with bear
just I just feel like why not talking
about bear enough dog who as Ellie in
the hospital you do hear someone yell
bear as you're killing a dog I think
it's the only time that someone else the
dog's name maybe happens twice and then
bear is this like this dog that you have
all these scenes where like someone
who's afraid of Alison dies yeah I think
I think it's bad that you you throw the
toy for in the aquarium though unless
unless I have the dogs confused
regardless [ __ ] devastating stuff but
I did lose my motivation in the second
half of the game because I'm just a lot
less interested in those people frankly
I didn't find myself very attached to
Mel or to Owen I liked the perspective I
don't feel like I should have spent
half of the game doing that stuff and I
had Ellie's drive I did love Joel I
still love Joel I agree that what he did
is wrong for Humanity but I care about
that character so deeply and have for
such a long time that I was angry that I
wanted to do it too and it wasn't that I
didn't see Abby's perspective because
from her perspective you see like in the
gameplay Haddad's this really sweet
loving guy she's dating a dude and he's
just like cute and supportive about it
in a way that you really see fathers in
media and he's a super positive and it's
also that you know from her perspective
and the fireflies perspective he doomed
the future of mankind and they talk
about how he's the worst ever and I was
also thinking about it like the way that
the WL have talked about Joel together
in a lot of those gameplay scenes I feel
like they built him up to be this like
you you know you can be in a group of
people and someone starts bitching about
someone and then they become the [ __ ]
worst and it's not necessarily true
right but you watch that happen with
them and I get why that all happened
it's just that I wasn't as invested in
her drive under any circumstances as I
was Ellie's and I'm interested to see I
feel like you haven't spoken how did how
did you feel about the second half of
the game well I mean back for the first
question I think that the main crux of
that whole thing was that Joel took
Ellie's agency away numerous times
throughout the game and that was the
thing that always came back to me he I'm
lying to her about all these things that
they spent the whole game trying to
accomplish while also trying to defend
while also you know make her into this
person that had this vengeful side to
her even in that first game so it's like
you're being trained to be to be vicious
within this world and then losing that
person and kind of transferring that to
from Joel to Ellie
seemed to be a really interesting space
like I think I think he got his fair do
in the game he was
yeah there's moments where he was loving
he had his moments where he was vengeful
he had his moments when he was a tear
cake tear a caretaker and I can't say
worse today didn't tear a lot of cake
though guys a good ass
yeah I did want to say Jess I think you
do have to kill the doctor I don't think
you have to kill everyone else I think
that you do you think you have to reach
up and upload I was okay with the second
high yeah I was okay with the second
half of the game like I liked Abbie's
arc I think it was a weird things I
basically reset your character halfway
through the game and make you do a whole
bunch of things mechanically all over
again which was a little bit annoying
but I think that that was a story
criticism of the embargo for the record
I thought it was good that we weren't
allowed to talk about that in the
embalmer yeah for sure
did that bothered me a bunch too because
I was like why why am I doing this again
I'm doing this whole thing again but
yeah like her motivation I thought was
was fairly well reasoned in the world
especially having had that flip of
seeing the other side of the coin of why
she became the person that she became I
thought was really interesting in that
space but again like the idea is that
all of that vengeance that was kind of
imbued into Ellie because I've heard
this conversation a lot about people
being like why would she that angry all
the time for most of the most of the
game I felt why she was she saw somebody
that she loved murdered in front of her
ass I'm the worst way possible and I get
it not freak out like I'm expecting that
to happen to a certain extent it were
people she shouldn't have killed for
sure but there were a lot of people that
I'm sure in that moment she had to yeah
look at all that how about you Jeff oh
sorry Jess oh god Jess yeah I guess my
question the drunk question I would
direct you Jeff what we saw go back to
Jess is um yeah how do you feel about
the second half again I love the second
half of the game I I think it's Abby's
game and from I should preface all this
by saying I don't hold the first game as
precious as some as it sounds like
several of you here do I never the first
game I think is is gorgeous and I'm in
in awe of it in a large sense but it
never clicked with me I never
loved it the way others do so perhaps
that explains why there's sort of this
inverse relationship perhaps between the
two games the first game never really
worked for me but the second game really
does and maybe it's because I never had
that feeling about Joel that some of you
seem to but I feel like the for me the
sequel is Abi's game and I I found it to
be an incredible refreshing surprise to
be put in the shoes of this character
there's so unlike any other character
I've ever played in a video game and
asked to consider first perspective and
you know here's this person that we are
we watch do this despicable thing in in
the most hideous way to a - to a
character that we are relating to and
empathizing with in the moment and then
we are in their shoes and are asked to
look at Ellie as the big boss that you
have to defeat at the end of the game
you know and I liked that juxtaposition
that that feeling of you know you guys
complained about sort of having your
abilities reset I liked I liked that I
thought that was a really interesting
choice and I liked the fact that her
abilities were different how she
approached things were different her
I've never seen a woman cast in the
brute role before this [ __ ] out of
infected and I loved it every time she's
the one who muscles up the chain-link
she's the one she's you know what's the
character from Final Fantasy 7 that's
the you know the big it's like these
Mary archetypes of like they're a parrot
right that's that archetype in
videogames is invariably a dude you know
and I just like how she liked all of her
it was cool to say here's this game
where you've been playing this kind of
character that does a certain thing and
then we put you in the role of Ellie
instead of Joel and she in the same
mechanical framework does things
differently and now we're in this other
character who also in the same
mechanical framework does things a
little bit differently and you have
these
it's it's it's subtle but I've I don't
know I I really liked the second Athen
game quite a lot I definitely like the
risk that they took in showing you the
perspective of the bad guy I'm into that
I love what SpecOps does with that kind
of thing
I guess my issue is that it's a full
half of the game I feel like I would
have preferred it to be bits and pieces
yes it's there's two ways to do this
like there's two ways to do this this
story concept one is to just swap back
and forth between them the whole game
which I think would have works a million
times better the other thing would be to
do what TV shows do which is like you
give it like one tenth of the rest of
the story like you don't split it in
half like this you like a TV show would
would have one episode they'll take like
one hour to like let's pull back the
curtain on the bad guys you know they
don't spend half the season doing that
you spend one episode and like they they
like split and did they they just did
the the worst of both stop both options
basically by seasons right it's it's one
season as Ellie and one season as Adam
but no TV show would ever do that yeah
that's not a that's not I mean I guess
that's like like one of the like some of
the Song of Ice and Fire books like
where some of them would would like
there'd be one book that focus they
inter won't perspectives that worked go
ahead sorry I got some [ __ ] to say so
the question of I actually think the
second half and here is this is coming
from the perspective I'm very precious
over the first game I love the first
game I actually wish but just hype that
I wish that actually what they've done
was seen for hours and whatever killed
both Ellie and Joel removed that there
this is not their game if you want to
kill everything's precious to me commit
to it and kill everything that's
precious to me and then tell the story
that is actually way more interesting I
don't think Abby is that interesting
honestly I think love and that their
dynamic together is in similar ways that
I don't find Joel interesting but Ellie
makes him interesting love and ABI did
the same for each other they have two
fundamentally different world views and
perspectives on the world and
experiences of the world and I would
have loved if this had been their game
entirely but my main problem is that I'm
sorry you have two female protagonists
were their entire lives motivations are
surrounding avenging their fathers and
they put all their whole lives
everything on pause everything about
themselves all their agency on pause
because daddy died and um I don't buy
that as a daughter myself I don't buy
that motivation especially as a daughter
of like an estranged shitty daddy I'm a
daughter I don't buy that that is the
entirety of my personality and my life
drives and I don't think if I had
someone who did something like Joel did
to me that I despite how complicated
that love is despite all of that that
can still say I wouldn't
literally risk everything I've built
which we've shown we've been shown
nothing but how Ellie had everything to
actually move beyond Joel move beyond
this vengeance that he tried to instill
with and within her and this like and
actually brings out her the best of her
right which is this perspective that she
believes that humanity is worth while
and she sees that proven to her again
and again with her relationship with
with Dina and like everything around
hers like Jackson seems like a place
that kind of mate let her have a normal
life but you're telling me that this one
year but this guy that's not even a real
dad who was a [ __ ] and who shares all
these like she's gonna go for his dead
body kill everybody and put everything
in her life and danger to Ford vengeance
it just just feel so empty so reductive
and vengeance but I should point out she
should be able to do the math on and
yeah I think like she should be able to
figure out yes that's it like she knows
yeah I probably deserved it like she
knows say that in retrospect
you know that she knows that he doomed
humanity and put that on her shoulders
and none of that makes sense to me as an
emotional drive for a character and as a
human being just like as a human person
and then Abby that's her whole
motivation to daddy died so I need
vengeance um I just don't know many
human women that are like that I'm gonna
stress look if I saw someone murder my
father figure in that way I would want
to [ __ ] kill them do it there's a
factor also of they had to ride their
horses from Wyoming to Seattle which is
like that's not a short trip you know
like that like you got a few days to
like calm down and like have have Deena
yeah like some whisperer nice things in
her ear I would be deeply traumatized I
don't know if I would literally risk
everything in my life around it I would
be deeply traumatized and in deep grief
and go through deep emotional states I
don't know my first instinct would be I
need to go kill every single person
involved in this I would I think I think
in the setting know that where we find
ourselves in within this game where lots
of people have lost so many things over
so many years and all the things that
we're kind of placing this in in terms
of the moral conundrums in the place
that you would wind up putting yourself
in a lot of that goes out of the window
when you have mushroom face zombies and
stuff so they like that loses a little
bit of it for me like I kind of
understand the vengeance part of the of
both aspects of Ellie and Abbie I think
to a certain extent the other thing I
actually really loved what you're
playing it was as a huge horror fan I am
so used to seeing delicate wallflowers
all the time oh you ran down the street
you tripped magically out of nowhere oh
it was dope to see two amazing women
characters bust people's asses for a
whole game because they were in their
most primal versions of themselves
deciding that this was the thing that
was going to carry
for the rest of their experiences to a
certain extent that to me was I'm not
gonna use the word brave it was
interesting to see that side of a women
characters be portrayed across a long
spectrum of the game - it wasn't like
this one flash-in-the-pan moment where
you got to see that bubble up and then
it goes away there's layers of that
energy that both Ellie and Abby have to
go through and they fight it from time
to time you see it in that one spot
where Ellie is fighting that woman in
the corridor in the basement before she
hits her with the pipe and you see her
hesitate she has a taste for a minute
she's like I don't I know this is gonna
be bad and this is gonna move me in the
direction that way I cannot stop going
after this but she still does it because
she feels like that means to an end is
worth it is it
I'm sorry in my head I thought you have
to in my head this is a world where you
kind of don't have anything to live for
but survival so I get why both of these
people got very attached to hating this
one thing because what the [ __ ] else do
you have to do like in Jack's gonna do
you sucks I [ __ ] know that I buy that
she loves him man I think she loves her
me there they're a married couple like
Deena Deena's like we had sex once yes I
will die for you and this man I barely
applied she got out of another
relationship a week beforehand matzo
belly and now they're suddenly [ __ ]
death do us part like you let me go into
the night with you I'll go to phantom
Deena if anyone would like to defend it
and Jeff if you like Tina I will also
allow them I just love her I love the
actress who plays her like I actually
love the scene in the synagogue I think
that was the most interesting their
relationship because it was about it was
like I was I said it was about like it
was about to people with fundamentally
different experiences of the world
experiencing the Last of Us world which
i think is one of those tensions
the only and it's the only time you
learn anything interesting about Deena
she says she's literally le but then
Jewish also I get into trouble by
comparing things to other things but I
will it's it seems to be a bit like I
understand your complaint about the idea
of someone wanting to go on revenge and
that being the premise of the game but
it's the premise of the game it's it's a
bit like saying hey I don't agree with
Hamlet being all upset about someone
killing his dad it's like what yeah I
know he does a lot of dumb stuff that is
ultimately very counterproductive
but that's that's the whole that's why
it's a tragedy right that's like a
Shakespearean book but um you know like
it's literature and it's not a game but
I discrediting the medium doges no I
don't think it's really not a game
I'm saying like it's a competitive
medium it's a completely I'm talking
about a story and I get that we're
allowed that tragic heroes exist that I
actually love a lot of video games that
do put you in the shoes of disagreeing
with the protagonist but I think those
games do a good job of convincing me I
actually think the first game did a good
job of convincing me because I cared
enough about Ellie to have that rage
even though it goes against a lot of my
instincts to have that rage that you
guys are describing heaven for Joel I
don't think Joel is a justifiable enough
character for me to want to have that
rage to avenge him I don't think he's
worth my vengeance and time and my life
so I love him so much it's so delicious
I I think he's hot as hell like I would
like avenge him you know I just don't
think he's worth that and I think like
actually the idea of survival if this
game really wanted to deal with drama
um I think Ellie like you can't say how
anybody like would respond to trauma but
in my opinion it wouldn't be let's go
back out there and do the traumatic
thing of that again if it's all about
survival wouldn't she bunk but like
buckle down with this stability that she
found in her relationship with Deena I
just don't understand what she would it
I don't think try I don't think the
theme of this movie was a scheme at all
was about trauma I think it was all
about revenge for multiplying you don't
think she's yes t and isn't having
flashbacks throughout the game that they
consistently bang you over the head with
yeah Abby is for sure I mean but playing
that one scene with them again and again
er oh yeah I mean I think I mean if I've
been shot at a couple times I wake I
wake up about that stuff to all the time
when stuff like that happens it's trauma
that's there but I mean in the game
itself the main motivating emotional
factor from so many different folks is
love revenge and remembrance in a weird
way where it's like you're the person
who brought me out of whatever it was in
terms of Joel to Ellie
Ellie's like yo at least I can do after
you have done whatever you've done even
though you have lied to me even though
you have kept me away from a version of
of a good life that I would have wanted
and it may be not or at least my
sacrifice would have been worth
something
she is weirdly honoring him by going on
this murder rampage which is also again
if that feels weird that feels weird but
it is one of those things look like
humans are motivated by so many
different things and to not include that
in the whole human you know diaspora of
like feelings is also just like I make
sense to me like yeah I don't I don't I
can't speak to anybody else's
relationship with their family but I
certainly know lots of people who have
the experience where you know it's I
hate him but you don't get to hate him
you know what I mean I get I can treat
my brother or my father or my family
member or whatever like [ __ ] but if you
do anything I will [ __ ] kill you you
know that that idea of even even if you
don't have this 100% wholesome love for
someone I think revenge is an
intoxicating emotion and one I it didn't
it didn't seem out of the realm of
possibility that even if she
feel completely at peace with Joel that
she would still feel motivated by that
horrendous act and I think and then we
find out later in the game that they
were very close to reconciling why she
was working through those feelings and
that I feel like that heightens it too
and you get to the point where you're
just about to say the things you need to
say to somebody and then you're that
stolen from you that moved me that
would've been such interesting context
to have during the whole game you know
that's another problem I have you know I
don't agree with it I actually still
don't like it but it would have been so
much more powerful and and I would have
so much more context to care about
Joel's death if I had known the
emotional context that this game seems
to withhold as if it's a plot twist I
don't get that I don't get why we're
treating like a character motivation as
like a plot dress like pod twist Ellie
was you know almost reconciling with
Joel I would have loved to have that
context and I think I would have
actually cared a lot more about Joel's
death if I'd known that I feel the way
that plays out was different in my head
it's like look again I maintain no
matter what I know that they loved each
other I would do that for my dad I still
100% [ __ ] get it like it seems like
most of the internet is like the most
mad about Joel's death so mad but they
don't even want to touch the kid like I
totally get I was [ __ ] furious I was
I was especially because he helped her
and then she [ __ ] kills him anyway
but you know I also get why it all makes
sense to me the reveal of it leading up
to Ellie finding out or everything that
you hear about their relationship at the
very beginning of the game is you know
he tells Tommy and it's alluded to that
that's the first time he's told anyone
and so you know off the bat that Ellie
still doesn't know so you have this
tension of at some point did she find
out is that why immediately after that
we see that awkward interaction between
them because that's the first
interaction I was like I assume some
[ __ ] went down and the only thing I can
think of is that she found out so I
liked the way that that like was its way
into that relationship and I think that
Jeff is absolutely right that it's like
when it comes to Abbey it's like I'm
allowed to hate my brother but you can't
hate my
I can call my sister a [ __ ] but you
can't call my sister a [ __ ] I'd be
furious and someone like slapped my
sister or something you know but I you
know I I mean I've never slapped my
system but I can call her a [ __ ] it's a
lap well it's fine I I get I get all of
that and I like that tension and I think
it's it is actually like an interesting
writing choice that the loss
conversation that Joel and Ellie have is
an argument which is actually the only
reference to either of them anyone being
homophobic is that someone in Jackson
attacks Deena and Ellie for kissing Joel
defends them hits the guy that is
implied that's the last document and
that's why I keep saying I feel like the
game respects Joel quite well because
you're starting off the game with him
being the hero who decked a homophobe
for her I mean I one of my friends died
in a car accident in the last
conversation that I had with him was an
argument and I feel like that does
change the context of someone dying is
that that's what you remember and you
feel like you wish you had done more to
resolve things and then you wish you had
said something different and I feel like
that's all of her actions are I don't
know just make a ton of [ __ ] sense to
me I don't know that that that abby's
are like again as interesting to me to
explore and maybe the one motivation I'm
like the least is the choice at the very
end for Ellie to walk away I think that
would have been a super [ __ ]
interesting if players got to choose if
it gives you moments to think about if
this is a whole game about revenge and
how everyone's shitty and on either side
of a [ __ ] argument different people I
mad at different things literally what
are you going to do and I think that's
like probably my biggest criticism is
that the ending with all of that writing
the lead up to it should have been a
choice so perfectly so on TV I wanted to
set my controller down and not fight
means you I the whole game actually I
mean like I don't want to do any of this
so I don't know I do too but I found
that compelling I thought that I don't
see I I've had a really hard time with a
medium that is about me especially
because I was someone who was so excited
to finally play a game the biggest
the biggest thing about the first game
that made me love it so much was that I
for the first time got to play as
someone who identifiably was relatable
to me and and I got to play as Ellie
what is that some kind of sweet tunes in
somebody's background is it really good
ice cream a time it is nighttime and
that is a 100% and not 918 parts of my
parts of my blocks like when it's time
to go home oh man at 9:00 p.m. the car
on I don't know I'm sorry I'm just
talking about like not feeling motivated
in doing really okay again I felt that
way a lot with Abby I didn't give a [ __ ]
about Mellon Ellen's I love the setting
I love love as my son protecting my all
cause also love what felt that like this
I will God died for you like I felt that
so immediately and I think that's like
it that's what pisses me off about this
game is that it actually has a lot of
potential but to me I just don't find a
game and I actually think that like
there is a way to do this I don't think
this is the way to do this because it's
so blatantly to me gives you this
revenge motivation but then
automatically distances you from Ellie
with all these with holding of her of
her interior tea I don't know what the
[ __ ] Ellie is feeling ever throughout
this game because it deliberately
withholds her interior world and
motivations she's a brick the most I get
is her journals it was kind of true you
don't she doesn't actually express a lot
except for like when the metal pot
happens really yeah I've been super
interesting like if the person who's
immune and this is all happening to and
like who's literal exists
is like the most interesting thing about
this world if I could know what she's
feeling as she's doing all these things
and there's a lot of assumption to be
made I guess but her and Deena are
really talking about it they're not
nobody's talking about I mean I did also
always find it weird that you're on a
revenge plot but then one of the first
things that you do is stop and play a
guitar for Deena five minutes like I get
every minigame those slaps oh my god it
did also make me emotional having that
happen because you have the context that
Joel told her guitar so I liked that but
I was still like if everything that's
driving me is revenge it seemed odd to
me that I am a yeah but I'm like hang on
love let me play a song it's perfectly
wonderful but yeah as anyone else have
opinions on the ending was what I was
gonna ask yes I didn't like it I thought
I thought it was a really weak ending
for a game that was fairly strong
through most of it I mean I like the
juxtaposition of having a be the you
know you know sunken from her from her
physical form that she was inhabiting
throughout most of the second half well
all of the parts of the second half of
the game except for the flashback parts
in that part it just felt like neither
character really got to walk out into
the sunset well or in a way that felt
satisfying in any real way like you know
Ellie Ellie gets to become Sarah Connor
and then Abby just gets to become you
know skinny and frail and ride off into
night and I don't understand that part
that part just made no sense I felt to
me it felt like the most powerful I
agree with you guys by the way I
I wish there had been a choice to be
made in that moment and it's it baffling
to me that it wasn't but to me the most
powerful part the ending is the New
Game+ menu screen yeah you know they
made it right they made it to Catalina
which is to me the most kind of
understated beautiful subtle little
thing to know oh my god but but then
sort of why not give
that in the actual game III it it did
not land it did not stick the landing
but so much leading up to it was so
powerful that didn't it didn't
completely ruin the experience for me
I'm gonna say like the moment I found
the most powerful if we're talking about
things that are powerful I already spoke
about bear really got me because I love
dogs and I had a chocolate lab that I
called Bear and it just it kicked me I
also really loved the museum I really
really loved it all the games quiz it I
was gonna say don't do that man yeah and
it took time to it like took the time to
sit with you through that moment of like
I think that's also where he teaches out
how to swim it doesn't rush you through
it I was super into that even if it does
the thing this game does all the [ __ ]
time and the gameplay where the doors
locked
you know like I know I have to go
through that door you're gonna open that
[ __ ] door at some point but it's
locked until you go in the shuttle I
feel like I'm replaying it right now
right and then just this is such a side
note but I feel like the amount of times
that I hear a character go
of course it's locked I'm like oh you're
saying that you know they love to
[ __ ] how are these walks this good
[ __ ] stupid doors but I didn't want to
ask everyone like I feel like that's
that's an interesting note it is a game
that is intended to make you feel things
including anger and I feel like that's
the thing that a lot of the conversation
is missing you are supposed to be mad
you're supposed to [ __ ] hate Abbi
I never liked a B in a way that I was
like it was impossible for me to
sympathize with her a put her on any
kind of pedestal I think she had the
moral high ground when I cared about
Joel as much as I did I did like that it
challenged that and made me see how
their world functions and how they all
feel but I never like was ever going to
be like I think it'd be sweetie I was
never in that mindset
it made me [ __ ] angry that's an
intense emotion it made me really happy
in the museum specifically that was
definitely something I felt really
strongly you're right everything to do
with the lab was awesome I thought the
the skyscraper building where Abbey's
afraid of heights that whole that the
intensity of that and the fear of that
was really [ __ ] cool the bottom floor
of the hospital where you have that big
blob guy boss fight was was
like a lot of different emotions along
the way so I just kind of wanted to ask
in a really broad way do you have a
moment that stands out to you as
particularly powerful I'm going to throw
this to you Phil no I I mean I actually
do like the very end like mm-hmm I don't
like this game
at like really but I like the last scene
I feel like that was like a very that
was like the most authentic scene in the
entire game at the very day when she
gets back to the foreign house and just
like sits down by yourself like like
that's that's there's a there's like a
realness to that thing that isn't to me
felt throughout the entire experience
well then if you didn't feel any
realness I guess I can I get you to
expand on that well the problem the
problem with video games is a
storytelling form is that you have to
commit to making a game that respects
the story you're telling and last of us
doesn't last of us - and the last was -
doesn't respect the story you like even
more so like it's just it's completely
at odds with what sorry is trying to
tell which is that this is a story that
probably at most is like an eighth
episode like HBO you know like this is
this is great
yeah sure story that would yeah but like
this is a story that doesn't support 30
hours this is a story that supports
eight hours maybe like I do you think
it's up so long so it's like it's it's
three if you know it's way it's twice at
least twice as long as it should be like
the first half of the game just the Le
part is one naughty dog game length you
know plus like um yeah no no I mean it's
like just the Le part the before you
switch to a be like that is the length
of the first game and then I don't want
the first game play another Jess I feel
like you probably know exactly how this
game oh yeah is your wife Angie that was
yeah yeah that's crazy like and that's
that's Ben
there that's been their sweet spot for
10 years you know since uncharted 2 it's
so like they just make games that are
like 12 to 15 hours long and like even
that I feel is probably a little too
long but I thought uncharted 4 dragged
on so ed states that the Lost legacy is
the sweet spot it's it's just ya can't
like you can't keep all this stuff like
in your mind like you can't think of you
can't keep all these character
motivations in your mind because it's
like I know a lotta you've heard me say
this like 10 times in the past couple
weeks but I like a great illustration I
think for for the problem the
fundamental problem with this game that
I have is when you first get to Seattle
and you got to open a gate and the
generators out of gas and so you got to
go find some gas and so you wander
around this open area for a couple hours
and eventually you find the gas and like
when I finally got the gas I couldn't
remember why I needed it because it had
been so long does take you a while to
get that yeah and and that's just what
the whole game is like is it's just you
can't when the story is stretched out
and like so full of like emptiness which
is just opening drawers looking for a
scrap pile of sand again yeah and like
or you you know you go to Hillcrest and
you have to fight through people in one
encounter the last 30 minutes or
whatever like it's just this is filler
this is what if you're talking about a
TV show you just say then spinning its
wheels with all this like filler stuff
in the middle that makes up most of the
game like this is the vast majority the
game is not the story it's the end it's
the stuff in between this one do you
feel like it's ludonarrative dissonance
that what that or is is tell know in
what you did like those SHIVs like SHIVs
this has been my pet peeve since the
first game really don't hate the sheriff
and I thought so much I got so much [ __ ]
for this back in the day and like it's a
shiv in the Last of Us is you have to
find
or scissor blades and then you tape them
together with duct tape and then they
break the first time you use them like
there's nothing there's nothing there's
no nothing realistic about that idea
there's nothing like it's purely a video
game mechanic right and it's just it's
just video game [ __ ] like it's just
the stuff that we kind of just
internalize and we just like let it go
we're just used to it because we play a
lot of video games but it's like this is
it's a it's at odds with like okay we're
gonna tell it rounded like human story
about people who have to taught tape for
scissor blades together and then those
scissor blades dissolve the first time
you use them like I understand how you
leave relates to your logic oh it's like
I get it it's just it's a weird
it's just separate like it's not the
story like you have to tell the story
like you have to be serious about
telling a story and like with with stuff
like that which is they're just
arbitrarily doesn't contribute to
anything it's just it's just busy work
it's just an activity to be done and it
doesn't speak to your motivation as a
character and in fact it doesn't even
make sense for ABI who literally visits
an armory and doesn't take a knife you
know like this would be the basic this
wouldn't be one of the basic you that
like very very well equipped and she's
like a bunch of the pistol every time
anybody goes out they would get like a
little bag that has med kits and like a
knife and like a pistol like it would
just be there would be standard
equipment you know like and just stuff
like that it takes away from I mean
there is because she goes up and she
says can I have the usual they check out
the dogs don't want to like they
literally you have which again I love
that [ __ ] I love seeing it I love it I
love that you carry your [ __ ] on your
back you can see yeah I loved it but
that's all of the original game it's
nothing to do this game I will say
though like to like I think that that I
agree with you felt like I did feel like
this game was too long and I've had this
thing where I have I love having my
friends text me while they're playing
through video games have already
finished cuz I feel like I get to
experience it again I love it and I've
had a bunch of friends spamming me like
telling me where they're at and stuff
and being like oh this parts super
annoying or whatever and the most
consistent thing that I'm hearing
absolutely everyone is geez this game
drags and I think that that feeling
comes from the sense that there are so
many encounters and so few set pieces
for a naughty dog game that it does feel
like you're doing a lot of busy work
that said and it's something that we
haven't even touched on because you know
I don't think many people are really
criticizing this part of it I I like the
game playing in this game so much better
than I liked it in public so much better
I think it's fluid it's as cinematic as
it looked in the state of play
it feels really [ __ ] good I find it
hard to put down even though I'm playing
it for a second time I love the gameplay
I really [ __ ] like it I also love how
much choice you have you don't have to
kill anyone or you can kill everyone you
can go stealth oh you can you can
[ __ ] kill a dog if you really want to
one time I shot one in the face with a
shotgun and it's the worst thing I've
ever seen I this is me someone I'm a dog
I adore my dog I would die for him I if
there's one person that killed before my
eyes I would go in a rampage that's what
I could say okay what if someone beat
Dex with a bass but he's a perfect angel
he's never done anything to this world
he doesn't deserve death and drilled us
anyway yep that's it she has a take I
respect that she has a take I have to
take listen I I love Joel I just I just
find his love to le perverse and [ __ ]
up and his whole character and that but
I will say like if the game had had the
balls to make me miss Joel but the
promise that the game kills Joel all
brutally and then does the cute thing of
bringing him back for the every other
[ __ ] flashback so I don't have time
to mourn Joel because Joel's in this
game the whole time and like if it could
have commit to that maybe I would have
felt some sort of the Vengeance but
unfortunately he's there the whole time
paternal I like being infantilizing
Ellie and like an interesting point that
he basically instead of you actually
seeing moments what Ellie is reminiscing
or feeling sad you instead get happy
moments ragazza Joel that is an
interesting choice that that stuff did
still make me the most emotional though
that
stuff is what hit me the most which
comes off the back of the first game of
course but I did love seeing all those
flashbacks those completely [ __ ] on
got a lot yeah I did too but it is an
interesting choice you didn't really get
a lot of that in the first game in that
way like you got snippets up man but you
did really get longer sections of you
know the actual minutiae of their
relationship we're away which I I really
loved that part I am glad to have seen
that stuff and I did just wanted to jump
back to basically everything Phil saying
about busy work and I'd really do every
time that I open an empty draw and it's
just full of sand again kind of make fun
of it but they also do this is one of
the things that I think Naughty Dog does
better than absolutely anyone else is
always well building and I still think
this game doesn't really good job of
wall building of setting up a scene of
what's happened to other people in the
world of making every outpost that you
ever go to feel like people live there
and that you wonder what they felt while
they were working there before they left
that [ __ ] is part of the gameplay and is
still really strong it's also the way
that they I feel like this is like a
step in the right direction that I hope
more video games do that I have not seen
many do but it's not quite there I do
like that the way characters interact
with each other so for example the way
this cars whistle just you know they're
loading each other to death and you know
do they gonna do that if someone doesn't
whistle back you know you have to go to
them I like hearing someone yell out
someone else's name when they see that
dead body on the ground like I really do
like the way that they tried to build
the the fact that this is about showing
multiple perspectives in that one [ __ ]
up world into the gameplay and I do
think they did a really good job of that
consistently it's just you're right a
lot of [ __ ] gameplay that I do I do
want to say I do love I do love when I
stab one of their friends in the neck
and then they find the corpse and
they're like oh they got ly like it's
like like I don't know if you ever if
you guys ever played soldier of fortune
or soldier for it into but like so this
this feels like the emotional version of
the soldier force to which is like or
both of those first games but you're
like super violent like merrier they
were
you know early 2000s or late late
nineties things but it was like you know
you shoot somebody with a shotgun like
in the chest and their intestines spill
out and it's like you know I was a kid
like playing this game and I'm like you
know I just would stare at it like oh my
god you know and and the the bad guys in
the last those two crying about their
dead friends is like the emotional
version of that for me so I just
actually occurred where you just like do
it in halo this is ya know that there
was in like an old Sonic game - shadow
yeah I saw that when it was like thank
you thank you Bob it's just like that um
I
yeah I think for me like the Ludo
narrative distance is so severe in that
like I I also hate how this game is like
here like a Neil druckmann like we don't
think about fun [ __ ] you you don't think
about fun this game is a [ __ ] ton of fun
to play I had to have violent actually
very violent urges despite what I did
this course I've been having here and I
go I think that's clear games have those
like you know expunged from my soul hey
Jesse one of the most fiery people I
know it's just I say everything they
smile oh yeah you get them but like but
I have having so much fun playing this
game and then it seems like bad no don't
do fun like don't have fun and it's like
I don't get like this simplistic view of
violence actually like this moralizing
of the violence that it forces you to
have fun and enjoy so that was an
interesting question is yes Neela's has
frequently been like it's not supposed
to be fun and I understand that from the
looking at the gameplay as like you know
you hear someone choke on their own
blood and [ __ ] massive credit through
the Naughty Dog for that design oh my
god
the sound design is incredible and also
the I've said this a couple of times but
I just want to touch on it because no
game has ever done this to me before
both the shamblers and the
Goo's physically make me feel ill to
look at physically my mouth waters
because I find looking at them so
disgusting
I don't think even a movie is if nothing
has ever done that to me before that I'm
like because I find them so funny but I
just don't look out up close it's dope
so it is extremely violent and
uncomfortable you're hearing people
scream out each other's names when their
friends die
you are le does this thing when she stab
someone she pushes it out so that blood
goes everywhere she's not it it's not a
pleasurable experience for her either I
gotta say I actually really I do love
the idea I don't think I don't think
they executed this well but I do love
the idea and I think it is brave of them
to have tried to do something that just
historically they've seen people have a
really hard time liking or enjoying
inhabiting the world of a female
character that is unlikable and Ellie is
throughout this game just unlikable
she's just making these kind of true
she's and she's will in a way that like
she doesn't bring sweet home the party
she just and I think that's actually
pretty brave of them to try to make you
want to identify her that I just don't
think they explored her interior -
enough for me to actually like be on
board with it um yeah I would feel like
that's intentional just because like
thinking about it you're right we don't
see a lot of Ellie's emotion we don't I
don't even feel like we hear from Ellie
that much I don't really know why I'm
like that much I would think that that
is because you are supposed to be Ellie
she's your link in this case she is your
vessel to feel angry about what's
happened which I I feel like you you've
got to be a [ __ ] outlier which I was
concerned I feel like most people very
[ __ ] angry of dying so I get if that
is the intention is for her to be your
link obviously I'm referring to Zelda
for anyone who's not familiar with the
franchise it's tiny that I I understand
why they would put you in that but then
again they make you do [ __ ] where I
think that most of like the pacing
issues cuz apparently someone beated in
16 hours which seems nuts to
it took me twenty one on my phone Scott
but apparently that is like fully
someone streamed it did you just not
look at anything are you playing I know
what he don't anyway why did you yeah
but I decided the whole game it's so
weird
I completely fit on my point was that
what did I say just sixteen do you think
when you asked like what who's
everyone's was powerful moments I was
really racking my brain I was like [ __ ]
I don't have a single thing
but I gotta say most of all most the
best writing in this game in my opinion
is the is letters and a lot of obviously
because there were video conventions the
like it's very hard to believe like it
that believably that these letters exist
but I actually think they are some of
the best writing in this game and had
made me feel the most and actually made
me like oh god I was interested in those
characters I was like why am i painted
Owen who the [ __ ] cares about Owen when
this like letter has this like deep
emotional like background and
interesting complex character in the
span of like 500 words bless God much
less and they do it they do a really
really good job of like they've not I
gotta say this reason this game is not
narrative lee which i think is what we
come to not ago dog for this game is a
five for me at best I think it's a
narrative mess but I I think everything
around this game is absolutely
unbelievable and a feat including the
gameplay so fun I keep playing this game
I hate yeah and and I think the guitar
it's genuinely mean like the small
moments and like skeeball background
things that go into making this world
feel lived in are like foreign on some
of the best I've ever seen in my entire
life I had three moments that I really
really liked I liked the part where Abby
was confronted by I forgot the name of
the pregnant character no hard man I
forgot her name but she basically called
her I was like you're a terrible [ __ ]
human being and you always happen yeah
you always have been and she stood there
and she didn't know what to do with that
energy he just takes a check and kicked
the chair and cried
after having had that intimate moment
with Owen and then not having to not
having to get a chance to kind of
reconcile that in the time that they had
to before they were gonna go do
something else which a mirror
I'm totally gonna come back to you but
is the thing worth noting - I feel like
the people who are really angry at this
game that haven't played it as much
this game doesn't present a be like a
good person I don't think aside from
what she does for live probably I do
think that like you literally have Mel
who's a person year almost inherently on
a biological level going to have
sympathy for because she's pregnant and
you've kind of [ __ ] her over a bit and
you have to help her in a lot of ways to
get through the world be like you're a
shitty person and you always have been
and I feel like it must be really
infectious when so much of what Abby is
saying to people is I found Joel we have
to go killin and now like do we really
want to do that cuz sometimes people
like is this a good idea and she's like
I don't know I don't [ __ ] care
and so it's like other people on her
side are also actively criticizing her
choice to go and do that it's not like
nobody dog decided it was the right
thing to do [ __ ] Joel like I feel like
that that's very clear in the gameplay
book sorry but attention go ahead no no
worries which I think was a what but I
felt like that moment with Abby was a
mirror of the moment where Ellie came
back to Dena with Jesse and they had a
discussion about being pregnant and
Deena and Jesse had that one kind of
like really sweet moment and Ellie was
not a part of that moment especially
after they had an intimate moment you
know a couple you know a couple of
scenes prior to that when they had
really they kissed and they smoked weed
and all that other good stuff which I
thought was really an interesting and I
think I think there was a moment
actually that I really wanted to see
kind of fleshed out more later like
kind of middle the story with Isaac who
I really liked as a character who didn't
get a lot of love at all if it was
really it just to see a black dude who
was the head of a militia with all the
things that are happening on in the
world today is that being a
conversational piece and him being the
leader of this side of the factions in
there which I thought was really really
cool also I didn't care about live I
wanted to love to die early it was like
I didn't care about love at all I care
about live some love is the best
character I let I'll say this is my
preface this love reminds me of the
character from the golden child from the
Eddie Murphy movie and I hated that kid
too yeah I think I like him for the same
reason I like to LA in the first place
was that you have someone who's innocent
in a Walt that's awful um the pregnancy
thing is a really interesting one of me
that would love to hear other people's
takes on this because I haven't actually
seen anyone else say this I feel like
pregnancy is used as a vice in this game
in a very yes waiting way so it felt to
me like you find out Deena is pregnant
so that Elly has extra most when she
kills Mel and so that there is an entire
it just feels like there is pregnancy in
multiple places is just plot device in a
very specific way rather than just a
thing that would happen in the world
well well it's it's it's extra it's
extra about it like just because because
having Deena be pregnant to like you
don't need that like a pregnant woman on
screen is like inherently like
sympathetic because you're like oh you
want to protect or you want to like
right there's like a biologic there's
like a biological like aspect just right
yeah human seeing pregnant women like
because you honor you understand like by
Allah on a biological level what that
means and like we collectively must hide
uation
yeah this is the continuation of the
species and all so like it's a
we inherently have that reaction or most
of us do and so like you don't need even
even need to like hammer it home by like
being like and also somebody you like
yeah that is how that felt to me yeah I
really think that every pregnancy and
this is just like first of all like oh
what a burden like every someone's
pregnant it's like oh can you believe
this [ __ ] my fab being in this universe
would be a [ __ ] nightmare
yeah except for the wlasiuk's more of a
problem like this is my pillow right
here I was I think I've had duct tape in
two pairs of scissors I think isn't it
is a really brutal thing to deal with it
also it's like a thing that I like they
made me consider where they talk about
like they do talk about I think it's
specific to Mel when they talk about how
they are going to deal with childbirth
in that Walden like again I just loved
learning about it and that's the thing
that I keep feeling with the TV shows
don't keep me Jolin I only give me all
the characters entirely and yes well
then that maybe that is a thing they
could have done with the second game but
I do feel like so much of what they were
trying to do with the writing is svet
expectations' and I think like a big
thing that's missing for a lot of people
which again Jess I really think you're
an outlier I feel like most people are
gonna be [ __ ] mad that Joel taught
because they love Joel is that like
people are just so mad that the the
points that come off the woods don't
walk like they effectively got them so
[ __ ] angry at that moment that
everything they tried to say off - that
doesn't matter because you're still too
[ __ ] mad about what happened to Joel
it's like it was - well the thing I
understand about that is like from all
the the promo material the art the kind
of snippets that they show in the
beginning right before we even got to
see any actual
no real gameplay or any of that stuff I
have an assumption that he was gonna die
we're like he's dead and then I thought
and then but we're like and and then I
was got wrapped up it's my problem with
Game of Thrones - in fan theories that
were much inch more interesting which
would be if we explored any amount of
Ellie's motherhood and any questions
about her mother oh yeah a question of
motherhood in this situation with Ellie
where she could potentially be passing
on immunity again I don't know why this
game completely ignores the most
interesting things about its characters
like Ellie being immune potentially
passing on if she was pregnant but until
you use this motherhood as this like
background of like God look how horrible
this world is right like this plot
device like kind of like you know games
have always been using rape women's rape
to be like God isn't this world dark
like it's just it's using motherhood in
this really utilitarian way that does
not explore anything about the mother's
experience or it's not even about
daughters is what I think I'm actually
super interested in dad stuff I've
written the whole thing I've I've turned
the term daddy apocalypse daddy because
we've had these stories and I eat them
up Logan is one of my favorite [ __ ]
movies of all time and I just find this
game to be emmitt like pretending to be
about daughters and actually be really
insulting because it's not it's it's
about their dads defining you know I
definitely think this game is not about
door design is definitely 100% just
about Joel I maintain that I really
think everything is about what Joel did
and how it affected everyone like it
really sucks
I never thought that they were going for
that angle though in the first place
they saw this as Ellie's game I mean I
don't but I don't think it's like the no
I feel like it was sold as a revenge
plot yeah
I don't think that they were trying to
go for any other angle but that thing
like I I understand that that would have
been nice for the where it's in that way
you put like in no way did I think that
they in any of the marketing in any of
the ways they talked about it that they
were trying to hit that angle in any
form or fashion and it's weird because
it makes me think of like we're talking
about the pregnancy angles of the game
it's probably one of the reasons why I
hate a quiet place as a movie because of
the fact that annoying pregnancy is
evening I mean the pregnancy is the
thing where you know again it's like
pregnancy in these Lane and in these in
these kinds of apocalypses are dangerous
having kids is dangerous where people
are still [ __ ] and exactly the I I
think yours making fair points about the
pregnancy for me obviously it seemed to
me that the the male pregnancy mirrors
the Dean of pregnancy and because Ellie
and Abby are supposed to be mirrors of
each other right they're supposed to be
two sides of the same coin and that's
why we see half the game from one
perspective and half game from the other
literally happening in the same time
yeah they view each other as their big
boss in their own video game and so do
we we're forced to deal with them as the
big boss in each of their own video
games it's to me it's like heat again
I'm not supposed to compare movies to
video games but you have DeNiro and you
have Pacino and it's it's giving equal
weight to both sides of the story I
think that's that that was the idea here
and so you have yes you have these
pregnancies mirrored but I also feel
like the the prism may have been there
to do the things that you guys are
talking about but it also gives weight
to the choice that Ellie makes to walk
away from this idyllic countryside home
that she's got she's literally just not
just walking away from someone she's in
love with she's walking away from a
child that needs her care that's what's
so powerful about when she returns and
they are gone not waiting for her she
made that decision that she has to live
with the ramifications of that
and I I found that to be very powerful I
want you go back to that you know
starting on that shot of her fingers
like I've never seen videogame fingers
that tell a story before story of that
of her life are in those fingers beyond
that close-up shot at her waist and then
she walks up to the walks up to the to
the house and it's empty and
everything's gone I that hit me like a
ton of bricks it was very moving I think
that's the reason why the scene where
they were dancing prior to that Ellie
and Deana with the baby and they go out
to the field and hang out with baby like
that those two scenes against each other
absolutely hit me - it was like oh man I
was like why are you gonna do this thing
why are you leaving
you have no reason we won you won you
got out and you're going back in so why
does she can someone explain that to me
I don't I don't like that part I don't
like that decision that's what I'm
talking about like that decision
inexplicable to me and I don't think
that any human being would act that way
like I I just didn't strike me as true
or honest and when Ellie leaves
first of all let's also just address
Tommy not dying apparently first and
then also coming in completely changing
his entire character motivation without
any warning he starts off the game being
like lock Ellie in a jail cell so she
doesn't go running after Joel I'm gonna
kill her and then he comes back and says
you [ __ ] you're not gonna go and kill
her for us when he's already told her go
do the murder when he's remembered it
that way she's in time the scene the
last scene we saw him in he was saying
we're gonna go back to Jackson and leave
a be behind that's what he said that's
the last time we interacted with him so
we saw this [ __ ] he went through and
none of that adds up to his character
just flippin motivations and then
guilting Ellie for not killing ABI he
was just saying that they should go back
to Jackson it's just none of the
characters ring true to me as human
beings with human motivations and that
was what made the first game so powerful
and I don't buy a single one of these
people as a real person
except man anyone who just watched in
the book Manny I get Manny I'm fully
sorry Jeff go ahead I couldn't not make
a sex joke I maybe I'm getting the
timeline wrong but I I thought he said
let's go back and screw a B let's leave
and then Abby shows up and murders
people and shoots him yeah the
chronology I feel like that can change
your opinion about something and he's
now he is now physically incapable of
doing the things that he said he was
able to do earlier he is now you think
after he's lost a bunch of people he'd
know how that revenge is a dish served
cold when everyone has just died and he
almost died and is his last person that
is his last remaining living being
connection to Joel to go probably died
with two Evandro like I just don't of
the game this is the theme of the game
and from my perspective and maybe I'm
miss reading it but from my perspective
the whole thing that the game is about
hate right yeah you see I mean one of
the most powerful sequences from my
perspective also is toward the end when
you are witnessing this war between two
human factions that you would think have
bigger fish to fry
but they hate each other to the point
where they set fire and you are
galloping through hell watching human
beings slaughter one another in this in
this apocalypse you know I'm reminded of
it rings true you know that this thing
that even in even when we can all agree
that there's a a common threat to all of
our lives you can all still turn on one
another and oh I I do not yeah I I think
human beings are more than capable of
being hateful towards each other I've
seen more than enough evidence of that I
just don't believe on a micro-level I
think that has actually the I also would
like to ask does anybody have any idea
what the Seraph ID
believe any of their belief systems
would have loved to have known anything
about that but like that that I actually
liked it there that fake it's a vehicle
I'm actually into that I'm in tonight
I'm getting a load up yeah I'm actually
really into the conflict I think that's
actually where their game is most
powerful and can say the most powerful
thing is on a macro level of like of
ideologies and that is interesting to me
but on a micro level of human to human I
don't know I just say like we've seen a
lot we see a lot of murder in this world
and you don't see those loved ones going
like I am now going to kill every single
person involved that's it's exactly the
point of the game is that you literally
do see another side having the same
feelings right that's the whole point is
that right I got out of it that's what I
got out of it is I mean there's a
there's a scene in one of the Austin
Powers movies where Austin Powers kills
one of the one of the thugs one of the
lackeys
and you didn't you go like see this
flashback of like all of the happy times
and that it's just like this yeah nobody
character and I kind of felt like that's
this game is kind of saying that to you
it's like everybody everybody is le
right everybody's the hero of their own
story most [ __ ] pass they do any 30
[ __ ] hours of my life to know that
you know that watched ten seasons of The
Walking Dead ok let Jeff speak it's
exhausting to defend the game but I I
don't think just because it's a theme
that we've seen before it doesn't
inherently make it invalid I'm perhaps
you're tired of it I I was and I it
resonated for me in a way that others of
those stories sometimes also resonate
but sometimes it was differently
resonant and I found it had some
interesting new things to say yeah
the theme is one that is familiar and it
has been said before and other types of
art and a lot of other ways and there's
a video jingle zombie game and movie I
mean I can't convince you that this
being explored before it doesn't make it
invalid oh I don't think I don't think
yeah it's not inherently it's not
inherently bad I just think it first of
all it does it for 30 hours and beats
you over the head with it and literally
just like moralize is everything in a
way that I find truly annoying and I I
love actually games about revenge my
when my favorite games of all time is
Red Dead Redemption one right would've
been two not stupid but the first game I
find that to be an amazing exploration
of a revenge story which happens with
the Sun and that that's true that's a
good example and like and then at the
end of the very game like and I think it
actually does it really cuz it's wrapped
in a satire and I think like telling a
revenge story like this Western revenge
story kind of requires a little bit of
distance and as opposed to this game
thinks I am going to be taking it out so
much at face value that I just don't
like as a human emotion when I think
it's actually more interesting in the
abstract as something that you explore
through the satire and the very last
[ __ ] thing on in Red Dead if you are
hit when you're done Marston Sun and you
go kill the people that killed your
father
and then at the very is just across the
the screen goes revenge or [ __ ] yeah
no it goes um god I forget yeah I think
it says like something like a basically
windscreen that's so obviously taunting
you I think that is a way to really
interestingly explore like a video game
done story this attempts to moralize a
video game revenge story to me feels
like like our front other friend phil
has been constantly saying it's like a
Mario in Mario you know they're like
that Goomba you just stepped on that
Goomba has a family it's just like okay
I just think look at this really base
level like I know other people have
daughters and
lives and I'm not the only protagonist
in this world like I just don't think I
need 30 hours and I don't think it's
that brilliant for doing that I feel
like this is like that particular issue
that you have is a very difficult one to
even discuss because that's just like
you genuinely not liking a theme like I
don't feel like there's any like middle
ground on that conversation because it's
just like you don't like that theme like
that's that's also totally fit like
that's also completely fun there are
other things that I feel like I like
easier to have conversations around
because it's like I just feel like
that's like especially subjective which
again also totally you know completely
fine we are running out of time it is
Phil's birthday I feel like I could have
done this for an extra five hours and we
would still have a million things
it's so [ __ ] complicated and I feel
like I'm like we could have finished
this thing like [ __ ] I should have
brought this up but I guess because it's
the topic everyone's really talking
about I wanted to ask you guys you know
the the a be killing Joel scene I guess
I'm gonna put you on the spot here but
that is the the most hotly-contested
scene is like people don't like the way
that that happened people don't like how
brutal it was do you think that was the
correct way to kill Joel as a character
to lead into everything else that
happened in the game and I guess why oh
why not you're not in college so I'm
gonna go with you first
I mean I'm a fan of gore so I don't get
I like gored movies on the car so I [ __ ]
you would get chopped up all that stuff
anyway yeah I mean I think in again I
even go back to horror right where
there's a conversation that always
happens about whether a character got an
honorable death
and sometimes in Gore movies the the
more gory it is is the more honorable
that you got in terms of that death I
think for what Joel was doing in the
first game what he did in the second
game killing all the everybody in the
hospital killed everybody out through
all the games that he killed people for
him to go out like that was kind of a
badge of honor
even though he didn't go out in a way
that felt satisfying for a lot of peope
like he was a person who was put in this
position to be strong and to not be weak
and to not be beat down in the way that
he was so to see that energy transfer
from him from that character I think was
an interesting play from from Naughty
Dog on that respect but in terms of the
actual gore for it like he will get
chunked up in this game from the get so
like for people to be mad about that
thing it seems a little bit weird so
well a lot of the complaints are that
Joel trusted strangers we do see him do
that drop this God a number of times in
the first game I feel like people are
kind of forgetting that but it is also I
feel like it was evident to me I don't
know if that that everyone felt this way
he clearly is softened like it seems to
me like very much as he has gotten older
he has become a softer character who is
less hateful and I think that's also an
interesting choice and then it doesn't
[ __ ] matter if he got softer or nicer
because what he did stuck with people as
a constant they didn't think well maybe
Joel's just the consequence don't give a
[ __ ]
so like that is a criticism I've seen
it's like why would they give their
names away like well why would they have
reason to think that they couldn't these
aren't random [ __ ] people who seem to
have an allegiance he does do that twice
and I think it's at least twice in the
first game where he's pretty [ __ ]
open with someone pretty much from the
jump but he's also just this nicer old
man I mean I don't know that I would
have written it that way like like for
me it worked because I needed to be
angry to have reason to like want to
push his le and yeah I was really
[ __ ] angry so like that was effective
for me I felt how about you how do you
how do you feel about the way Joel was
disposed of I mean I think I'm fine with
it I think it's a it's obviously
intentionally upsetting we saw this the
same thing happened a few years ago on
The Walking Dead where Glenn got his
face beat in you know with a baseball
bat and it's like there was it was like
that was traumatic and this is this is
basically just that and it's just it's
really just about kind of [ __ ] with
your head and like putting you in a
blood rage and that kind of thing it's
supposed to make you like you're
supposed to be upset as you consume the
rest of it you know so I like I'm fine
with it's doing
they managed to do what they wanted to
do with that which is make you real
upset even if you like even if you like
not actually upset about like I don't
care about the first game really and I
don't care about Joel that much
I mean he's fine he's just whatever and
so I wasn't like I wasn't like upset
that like my favorite dad my favorite
videogame dad died or whatever but like
I was I was more upset that I would have
been had it been less violent you know
so I think in that way it accomplished
what it was trying to do so yeah I
definitely feel like it accomplished
what it was trying to do I feel like
that's the that's the main point is it
accomplished what it was trying to do I
also feel like and maybe this is me
reading into it but this is a thing that
I like that I had the ability to read
into it I like to think that old man
Joel [ __ ] knew he had it coming like
I I feel like he would have been sitting
there being like what I did to those
fireflies that was sort of their whole
purpose every single one of them knows
that I did that probably gonna [ __ ]
hate me forever
and that's like a testament to how much
he loves Ellie and how you see that
relationship growth in the first game is
like that's that's the strength of that
that's part of the point it's trying to
make but I like to think that even when
he's [ __ ] sitting there and that's
happening he's like yeah I was probably
gonna get murdered by some ex Firefly at
some [ __ ] point and that's pretty
much exactly what happens so I gotta
agree surprisingly I think we all agree
on make sense my one point of contention
is that it pales in comparison to what I
think it's trying to imitate which is
Sarah's destiny in the first game in
terms of devastating me in terms of
actually summoning some sort of like
very human emotion yeah I think this one
did a lot less for me for as long as I
like and actually you expect both right
you don't expect Sarah to live we all
know that but we none of us expected
Joel to live no that's the weirdest
thing is we all forgot that we all
[ __ ] knew he was gonna die yeah yeah
whoa no no I didn't know surprised and I
think the violence is appropriate for
the tone of the whole aim yeah I think
it's fine and like yeah he did soften
and I hope
I hope he does but I actually don't like
is that they he never does kind of like
reckon with the amount that he's done I
don't think like Laurie seems like he's
just he really like when you go through
his house he's really just a retired man
who was just tried to escape from it and
yeah I feel like that is a realistic
thing to happen but you're right it
would be interesting to see him struggle
with it well you what you don't Jeff do
you have any thoughts on the way Joel
dies you guys have all made excellent
points I don't have much to add my only
audition would be that I appreciated I
found it very upsetting very upsetting
but also there was no doubt right there
was no doubt which is I think true good
that you didn't go through the game
going what is he coming back you know
there was you know that what's that
adage in fiction nobody know death right
there is no light falling off the cliff
there was no getting shot and you know
in collapsing there was it was certain
right so I found that to be pretty
powerful
yeah you can't comic book him coming
back to life that you're right that was
an important thing to actually finally
not even want him to come back as a
clicker oh [ __ ] that would have been so
bad
all right like I said I feel like we
could do this for way way way longer but
I won't keep you
whose birthday but thank you all for
joining me and for having respectful
discussions with something we all feel
very passionately about
I guess just very briefly does anyone
have any like major closing thoughts I
think it's awesome if somebody got to
fill an entire truck worth of ice cream
first there was fireworks before
rightful yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're in New York just because the
fireworks here yeah I wanted to just say
thank you to everybody here I actually
love that we can have a passionate you
know debates about completely different
opinions and I actually Creed with a lot
of everything that everybody said we
just I guess like the the literal final
thing that I want to say is no matter
what even if I say this game is a seven
out of ten and Phil seems like honestly
more like a two and then I thought
before being real sentence like the main
thing I like were I've been talking
about
yeah I'm my seven or eight I think um
one thing that I've been talking about a
lot this week that I just want to
reiterate here that I am sure you will
agree with is that I completely
understand people have different
perspectives and if you think it's a ten
that's what you believe like I'm like a
hundred percent like [ __ ] love when
games roll around like this one why
people feel really really passionately
about it enough to keep what I'm talking
about it especially when it's something
to do with the story like if you [ __ ]
hate it or you [ __ ] love it I love
that out medium is encouraging
conversations like these that are so so
so diverse based on what people bring to
it all which characters they get
attached to you
I'm I'm [ __ ] glad it came out right
now me too and yeah thank you all for
sharing all of your again I I do think
well-reasoned impassioned impressions of
the lost of his plot to everyone on the
internet play it what the [ __ ] is that
Phil copyright claim people walk like
five feet from where I'm sitting right
now
your audience is like a clicker either
way all right Phil where can people find
you I am on the rap comm WRA P Jess oh
yeah sorry
oh and
you can I have a blue check and work by
my name at Joe on twitch Instagram and
Twitter mostly for my garbage hot takes
please go there and on Mashable calm
rime a staff writer and I write about
not just video games but a whole lot of
other things sex toys and his ex toys
yes all this fascinating stuff
Jeff at Jeff kanata on Twitter I do a
video game podcast called DLC and can
find it at 5x5 TV slash DLC and if you
want to see what stories I come up with
I make an epic long-form story of my own
on a Dungeons & Dragons podcast called
the dungeon run you can find it by
searching for the dungeon run on YouTube
or as an audio podcast while watching it
Wednesday nights at 6 p.m. on caffeine
TV slash the dungeon right it is on IGN
right now zoom coals are just a lot of
sorry oh sorry go ahead
Kaja Akins is the personal account at
spawn on me is the one for the show I
run this wannabe podcast the premiere
podcast
well letting people of color in the
video game industry we have stuff on all
podcast platforms YouTube Instagram all
those places so check that I will add a
description to leave everyone's links
there when the video is no longer live
so thank you for all joining me have a
good night yeah we did it
you